Fran Fraschilla here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you friend rich they clear
cap space for me I hope you're not
making what I'm making
that's hilarious and Fran is here is
part and parcel of the Honda inside a
report brought to you by the Honda
Accord good to speak with you friend
pleasure so is it Aton first up you
think let's start with that what do you
think okay done deal
not even close I mean it's close but
this kid is a unique big man we're
talking about a the new era of the NB a
small ball versatility but he's 7 1 to
16 feet great he's a tremendous athlete
he's got a killer instinct that we
didn't see in high school because he
just kind of floated but he told us this
morning when we got a chance to
interview him on a serious NBA radio
that Sean Miller really dared him from
day one to bring answering every single
day and rich when I watched him in
person and on tape his upper level is
high and this is a you know it's a it's
a no-brainer
keep in mind you and I would notice but
not a lot of listeners the last time the
Phoenix Suns were in this position it's
the first time they've ever had the
number one pick they lost a coin toss
for Lew Alcindor and they ended up with
Neal walk so it's a good day for the
Suns tomorrow night there's no get a
chance to get a franchise player so then
if you are next up in your Sacramento
who do you pull the trigger on right
there oh no this is the tricky one and
the toughest decision in the draft
because they're staring at you know
Marvin Bagley a precocious high school
kid who you know can be a young man that
went to Duke and put up 20 and 10 this
year or you know again in an
international man of mystery look at Don
Cheech the 19 year old wunderkind from
Slovenia and it looks like you would say
with with Glaude there with pages lack
of age as the assistant GM that Don
Cheech might be the guy but this is the
tough part for a body they cannot get
this wrong rich I would personally take
Marvin Bagley
but this is a this is going to be the
call of the night because everything
else after the GaN th Bagley picked for
the Kings will determine I know where
everybody else falls so they've got the
toughest job in the draft so what about
the idea that John Donne church is more
polished than porzingis was and we all
know what a purple unicorn he's turned
out to be what about that friend yeah
well I think there's no question he's
the most decorated player to ever come
out of Europe as a young player now is
he gonna average 30,000 is he going to
score 30,000 points like Dirk probably
not because we have the you know there's
unique physical ability of Greek freak
probably not we win championships the
way Gasol has will see that that remains
to be seen but what he is is the best
way to describe him rich is think about
Gordon Hayward type physical ability and
skill with Manu Ginobili sprain
this kid is quick of mind Larry Bird
like magic LeBron like in terms of the
way he sees the game I questioned some
of the athleticism so that's why I would
go Bagley but this kids a unique toy or
if only because of what he's done at
such a young age in Europe he doesn't
have the 72 wingspan and athleticism of
porzingis but he's uh he's got an
incredible feel for the game so then why
do you go Bagley over Dantas year I I
would feel more comfortable knowing
knowing that what I saw Bagley is a kid
that again nearly seven feet very
athletic can score plays with a high
motor you know I think he's a guy that
Sacramento could plug in and get 20
points and ten rebounds next year Fran
Fraschilla here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you think the hawk should go at
three then Ryan well then I think then I
think they'll go da judge because
they're rebuilding again he is an
incredible teammate new the new coach
Lloyd Pierce has been in Philly with
Simmons he's been in Golden State with
Steph and klay Thompson I think this I
think Don Cheech would be a nice
building block for the future
because again and and let me tell you I
could be wrong about him going to and he
could end up being a guy that Sacramento
builds around but if if I'm if I'm
feeling badly at 2:00 then I think Don
Cheech has to go 3 so who do you think
has the who's dropping who do you think
is is dropping right now night before
the draft Tran well III never subscribed
to rising and dropping rich because I
think teams have a good sense of where
these guys are but what I would tell you
is when you talk about Michael Porter Jr
you know the young youngster out of
Missouri who had back surgery in
November what fans have to realize is
that before you talk talent attitude
character work ethic intangibles with an
NBA owner you got to talk about combat
achill you can't be a GM that goes to
your owner and says look we got a 50-50
chance of drafting this Michael Porter
jr. and he's going to remain healthy for
10 years because of the back surgery
he's the one guy that could slide down
to the you know two nine eight nine or
ten because as as I've checked with
surgeons or do you have back surgery
there's an 80% chance you're going to
get to be completely healthy but there's
the 20% that you won't especially tall
guys and especially guys who fly on
charter flight flights all season and
have to sit in these airplane seats so
Michael Porter is a tremendous offensive
talent but given the fact that you got
Bamba and Wendell Carter and Bagley and
Aten I think Michael Porter Jr drops
because of the question mark with his
back I'm just looking at prospect
rankings right here with Fran Fraschilla
in the Honda inside a report here on the
Rich Eisen show I mean it takes a lot to
see the word jr. and I'm not talking
about because it you know and in the
name I'm talking about the number of
years in college what's been the
conversation around the draft about the
won and Duns and what the NBA needs to
do to fix things in the the light of
what was going on and still is in courts
in the FBI Frank well it's it's easy
rich within the next year or two they're
going to do away with
and done and they're gonna we're going
to get back to where we were when
Carmelo and Dwight Howard and some of
the other guys went right to the NBA
Draft I'm all for it you know we had a
great conversation with you know miles
bridges this morning the young man from
Michigan State who chose to give up
being a lottery pick last year to go
back to college and he said he said to
us he said I wanted to be a college
student I didn't want to have one foot
in the door and one foot out and when
you get a kid that goes to a Duke or
Kentucky or anywhere else where there
are one and done essentially you're
renting them for about five months and
so now that the Andre Ayden's and the
Marvin Bagley's can go right to the NBA
out of high school like the kid at Tampa
Catholic who throws 97 miles an hour you
know he doesn't have to go to Florida
State he can sign with the Cincinnati
Reds and and so I you're gonna see that
the one-and-done is gone by either 20 or
21 and personally I think it's great
there's now the kids who go to college
by the way like trae Young who never
thought he would be a one-and-done guy
but he has a great freshman year he can
still come out and explore the waters
and if he didn't have this fabulous a
year he could have gone back for year 2
year 3 etc but I think it was a charade
to let these kids come to college
knowing that they really should have had
the opportunity to go right to the weak
and succeed or fail which is you know in
their in their power so where do you
think is the right fit for tre Young
it's all said and done the man it's a
great question I you know the first
logical place looks like Orlando because
Dallas at 5 already has their point
guard of the future in Dennis Smith and
Orlando has been as and had a man they
haven't had a point guard since Scott
Skiles okay so who by the way has the
NBA record with 30 assists in a game but
I I think Orlando makes sense there and
if it's not Orlando at six then you got
Chicago at seven and and then you know
to me he'll be gone by eight or nine but
uh you know to me he's not Steph Curry
forget that just be Mike Connolly for
now you know if you tre
young just come into the league and be
Mike Connolly and don't try to be Steph
Curry a couple more minutes with Fran
Fraschilla here on the Rich Eisen show
give me some names of some other foreign
players so fans who don't get upset when
they've never heard of or seen him play
and they become a first-round pick
tomorrow night what do you think it's a
quiet quiet year you know it's uh yeah
it's not a great year there could be
only two first-round picks but I will
test I will show you the breadth the
depth of my pronunciation ability also
friend now let's go Zana
Moussa from Bosnia 69 small forward just
turned 19 he'll go probably between 15
and 25 and then Elio Cabo terrific young
guard from France who's about six foot
four remember to French guys do well in
the NBA
Tony Parker Colbert you know Boris Diaw
etc so it's going to be a quiet night
but you know what I will not be on the
draft I will be on this five-hour begger
cast show with with Rachel Nichols and
and Brian Windhorse my man Tim Lake Lure
I'll be great so I'll get a chance to
wax poetic on all the colleges what's
that going to be on ESPN plus espn2
what's it gonna be on espn2 at the same
time and uh just will will will will
complement the the live coverage of from
Berkeley last thing for you I just
wanted to get you got a couple minutes
just stroll down memory lane with you
with the what the sirens going on in the
background there in New York there's a
very new moment about what about to ask
about a prospect out of Queens Bridge
New York back in the day Fran we've had
him on the show as Metta World Peace you
were the one who recruited Ron Artest
what was he like back then I think
they're coming to get Ron right now is
he driving another Lamborghini down the
street another f1 the down there down
the street let me know it's possible I'm
looking outside if no I think it's not
Ron no it might be one more row to wait
a minute but uh no but I got to tell you
people say how did you coach Ron in
college and I said it's very simple I
had to be crazier than him so whenever I
saw him in practice start to bubble
but start to lose the temper I went into
full tranfer Shella crazy mode and I
went crazy on the entire team and this
way he calmed down and he would come
over to me and say Kody relax
everything's okay
so when I would see the temper come out
I would actually get crazier than him
and it ended up having we ended up
having a great relationship and he's one
of my favorite people and you guys have
gotten to know him out there yeah heart
heart as big as gold most competitive
guy I've ever coached on the court off
the court he would give you the shirt
off his back
are you aware he's become friends with
the guy who threw the beer at him in
Auburn Hills in the palace are you
friends - did you know that he's
contacted I mean knows who he is he's
had conversations are you where that
friend no no but it's no surprise he's
one of the gentlest kindest guys you
guys remember about ten years ago he was
the NBA citizen the Walter Kennedy
citizen of the year because of what he
did in Africa so he's a fabulous guy and
I'm really proud of him because I've
known him since he was 15 years old and
got a chance to coach and got a chance
to set him on his way and someone told
me rich I'll leave you with this they
said what do you think of Phil Jackson
someone asked him he said great coach
great coach and then someone said what
about coach Fran he goes the coach for
the purpose of this conversation if
there are more than one friend for
sheilas I'm glad I got the Fran world
peace version I'm glad I got well there
you go take care of Fran thanks for the
inside have a great time on the mega
cast tomorrow night thank thank you rich
you got it that's a Fran Fraschilla the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience